vous avez déjà essayé de vous arrêter
fumée à saint-louis jamais c'est pour
réussir tueur essayé gemmrich it
la cure médicamenteuse le produit
proposé aux candidats est un produit
nouveau non commercialisé c'est
réellement un médicament qui a donc fait
la preuve de son efficacité et qui
présente un double intérêt à la fois
théorique et pratique un intérêt
théorique car il s'attaque au processus
même de la dépendance qui est le besoin
de nicotine un intérêt pratique immense
car il va permettre un certain nombre de
grands fumeurs dépendants à la nicotine
d'obtenir un sevrage
[Musique]
cette jeune femme fait partie des
premiers volontaires à avoir testé en
france le patch anti tabac son
utilisation est simple le fumeur doit
placer chaque matin sur une partie de
son sort le timbre à nicotine
traitement miracle sans doute pas
traitements chers certainement
chaque patch coûte environ 20 francs et
on doit on utiliser près d'une centaine
pour parvenir à un véritable sevrage et
bien sûr tout cela n'est pas prise en
charge par la sécurité sociale
[Musique]
dans les pharmacies la nicotine est est
vendu jusqu'ici que six ordonnances
désormais les gommes à mâcher la
nicotine destiné à aider les fumeurs à
arrêter la cigarette sont en vente libre
je pense qu'on a un rôle à jouer en tant
que conseil il faut vraiment prendre le
client par lui expliquer les avantages
et les inconvénients justement de ces
patchs
[Musique]
vous avez à une batterie
en gros une batterie un vaporisateur et
une cartouche de nicotine pour charger
la batterie se rallument figaro
électrique et après ça chauffe
et donc quand vous fumez c'est la vapeur
d'eau qui saurait pas de la fumée
[Musique]